[تقدير]
كا زنداباد جيبا
تحيا تحيا تحيا
زيمبا فاز فاز فاز واضرب واضرب نظرة
كيف تأخذ التمويل؟
يرى
مهما كان المتظاهر تجاه سفارة إسرائيل
وبدأت الشرطة في اعتقاله وهو ينهض.
انظر هنا بأعداد كبيرة
الطالب الذي هو طالب هنا هو إسرائيل
انظر هنا من كان يخرج من السفارة.
إنهم طلاب، يجلسون في الشوارع ولكن
بدأت الشرطة باعتقال الجميع
[موسيقى]
فانظر هنا هناك امرأة.
الشرطة تحتجز هذه العودة الإسرائيلية
بمجرد أن ترفع المرأة شعارات
لقد وصلت إلى هنا، أنظر هنا
انظر إلى السيدة هنا وهي شرطة السيدات
اعتقال الجميع هنا
جاء المتظاهرون، واعتقلتهم الشرطة جميعًا
بدأت تفعل
أنظر، هناك عدد كبير من رجال الشرطة هنا.
القوة الحاضرة
أنظر هنا كأنك متظاهر
وصلت الشرطة إلى هنا واعتقلت الجميع.
أخذ
وها أنا أعرض عليك من هنا
أنظر إلى القبلة هنا
عطوف